For years, people have asked how we make our videos.
So let's finally talk about it, how to make a coats.
Cause aren't a video in 1200 hours.
Well,
first things first.
We need a topic. Our potential topic list is already endless.
And every time we research something, it grows longer.
So we just work on whatever we find exciting at the time.
This could be something serious, fascinating, personal, or just really stupid.
The variety is half the fun.
We want to explain complicated things in an easily graspable way and make
sciency topics fascinating and beautiful.
But we also want to tell stories and express how we feel about the universe from
time to time laying the foundation script.
Our search begins by reading books, all scientific papers,
and by talking to different experts who point us in the right direction,
we want to have a fact-based worldview and our videos are trying to reflect
that. So we often have to change our view on an issue while working on it.
Usually after a few weeks of researching, we start writing a script,
begins with a rough first draft that then we resonant and edited over and over
again, to make sure we don't misrepresent something.
We ask experts to fact check and correct us writing is the
bottleneck for our videos and very hard to speed up.
Usually finishing a script takes between a few weeks and literally years to
complete. Let's visualize illustration.
When the script is ready, we begin sketching out the video.
We try to think of visual metaphors transitions between ideas and decide which
scenes need the most attention on average,
200 panels need to be illustrated in Adobe illustrator.
Although we have built up an illustration library,
we still do most illustrations from scratch to give our videos a more unique
look.
The general idea is to find the right images to the words in the script to
explain as clearly as possible while also having interesting things to look at
them.
Also here we include all the visual Easter eggs in total
two to three illustrators spend eight to 12 weeks illustrating the video.
Now it's my turn and duration.
When the whole video is illustrated,
the duration is recorded in a small recording studio on a noisy man TLM one Oh
three microphone and pro tools. It's important to keep the flow.
So I try to get one version done and then go back through retaking paragraphs
and sentences until they feel right. And a full version is ready.
It's alive animation.
Now the scenes and audio need to be animated.
We make things in Adobe after effects and recently we've begun experimenting
with cinema 4d.
The first thing to do is take the illustrated scenes apart and organize them.
The hundreds of thousands of parts are then imported into after effects.
Each character is rakes so we can move them more naturally
aside from a few plugins that help us save time.
Every single thing that's moving on screen has been moved manually.
So two to three animators animate scene after scene for about eight to 10 weeks
in total,
ending on a high note music and sound design.
The funnel step is the music.
Every song is original music composed to the finished video to create a unique
atmosphere and to highlight the important parts.
You can listen to all of the songs on SoundCloud and Spotify,
the icing on the cake, other sound effects.
Many of you might not even really notice them,
which is a shame because they really add an additional layer.
So try watching a video with headphones,
if you want to get the full depth of it, all of these steps happen in parallel.
Since we usually work on two to four videos at the same time in various stages,
what we haven't mentioned are the countless revisions and edits. Every few days,
we sit together and review our work and tweak it until it feels just right.
And that's it at least 1200 hours for a single codes. Cause art video,
as you can imagine, making videos for thousands of hours is a big team.
And then putting them on the internet for free is a weird business model.
Over the years, we've relied on a number of different things to stay afloat,
commercial work for NGOs, startups, all corporations, sponsorships,
and grants by companies or organizations.
We struck a deal with folk from German public broadcasting to revive the German
channel and with Wix to start a Spanish channel.
But the reality is we can only do what we do because of you.
Our two most important sources of income by far come from your direct
support merchandise and Patriot.
So if you want to help us stay afloat and keep making more videos,
you can directly support coats cause art,
by getting something beautiful from our store all by becoming a Patrion and
joining the bird army, don't feel obligated though,
watching engaging or sharing our videos is already helping us a lot.
But if you want to support us directly, thank you so much.
You're making our videos free for everyone.
You are enabling us to practice and improve,
to stay independent and to work on ambitious projects.
That would be too scary or too big.
Otherwise coats croissants did not start with an end golden mind.
It began as a personal project because it felt good to make something with time
and love. And this is still true today.
Making these videos is our goal doing work every day and getting better
to make science. Beautiful and interesting.
Thank you so much for sticking with us for seven years.
And from our first subscriber to the 10000000th,
this journey has been so wild and so much fun,
and we can't wait to share the stuff we're working on right now with you in a
year or maybe two.
We want to make massive videos like this from time to time. Now,
if you want to ask us questions that you want us to answer,
you can do so on Reddit link.